this is a story that we have to verify
this happened or not so
uh this is not a snopes story this is a
guardian gazette story biden reportedly
pooped his pants at the vatican
reports are broken out from the state uh
uh
that state joe biden pooped himself
while meeting up with pope francis
rumors have been floating around that uh
rome that biden unusual long meeting
with the pope wasn't because the two
were best friends but rather was a
result of biden having an accident
according to american journalist jack
posabic
the live stream of biden and the pope
meeting was suddenly cut off when the
two met which raised many speculations i
was noted by the other sources on the
ground in rome that biden had a bathroom
accident
after the news broke out users on
twitter created memes and even had
poopypants biden trending on twitter
other users pointed out that biden had
different pants after meeting the pope
then he had on before meeting the pope
according to alex jones the host at
infowars secret service frequently
reported biden soil himself jones
reported on biden uh being unable to
control bowel movements came two weeks
ago but now it looks like his reporting
isn't a conspiracy after all after legit
accident biden looked very lost as world
leaders gathered together at the g20
rome summit photo biden was lined up all
the way to the left usually the u.s
president stands in the middle but biden
isolated himself from everybody and
chose to stand off to the side do you
think this happened so hurt i don't saw
her i just
i'm not even gonna give an opinion here
i'm just gonna give i've watched both
uh cnn msnbc cover this and i've watched
fox news and apparently this guardian
it just it amplifies how polar opposites
we are living in in this world right now
on one hand they're they're showing
images of biden
um and the pope getting along best of
friends look at these guys they
juxtapose that with how upset the pope
was with trump or didn't have a smiley
face on they're basically
showing how all right they're best of
friends that's great and then you turn
on slides happen both sides exactly and
then you turn on to the conservative
media and it's like bad [ __ ] his pants
it happened facts he can't
he can't he can't control himself it's
dizzy it's
like dizzy from spin here so you know
guys go ahead be be children and comment
on this story go ahead do do you think
go ahead children that it is the adam
scott's calling people children that's
hilarious the do you think that it's a
bad thing that it's completely and
totally plausible yes whether it
happened or not right do you think it's
a bad thing that is completely and
totally plausible that the leader of the
free world should have passed there
isn't one person that doesn't think that
is probably how did it happen we don't
know that's like saying do you think
trump got pissed on by a bunch of uh
prostitutes it's not like saying that at
all because i think that's actually more
likely
trump getting pissed off
by a bunch of prosecutors
in all fairness to poopy joe they he you
have not sent cass the first stone i
i've pooped my pants unbelievable
there it is there's the short clip right
now gerard is full on admitting that
he's a booby pant here's the deal it
wasn't when i was uh dressed in i had
the flu and i was stuck in
bumper-to-bumper traffic on the new
jersey turnpike and i had literally no
other options i wasn't so excited to see
the pope that i [ __ ] myself but you know
maybe i don't know i i don't know like
maybe who's the superstar maybe if i
maybe if i got a chance to meet johnny
bench i'd [ __ ] myself too i i i i don't
know like maybe
this is where we're at right now he knew
half thought exactly this is where we're
at right now that the leader of the free
world met the leader of one of the
largest religious sects in the world and
was like
maybe and it's completely plausible yeah
i think and then you and then you took a
page out of his book and admitted that
you do the same hey may he who have not
sent me
every infant on earth pat's new puppy
and the president of the united states
there you go we just let it fly
it's all shits and giggles bro
it's all shits and giggles until
somebody giggles and shits themselves
right they hurt like yeah it's all it's
all [ __ ] come on
it's okay though no no mean tweets
though no mean tweets so you know orange
man still bad let's do that
you're never gonna alleviate this is the
story i think it's a metaphor for his
presidency
you know i think it's
as virginia goes the rest of the country
goes adam why does this why does this
bother you so much
i just think
i think it's like we're having so many
intellectual conversations we're
actually having a good debate and it's
like let's let's end with a [ __ ] story
yeah you don't think it's weird that
everybody in the world literally
believes that yeah this guy could have
[ __ ] well here's here's the biggest
hyperbolic everybody in the world
we all think it probably did happen but
why can't you just excuse yourself and
go find a restroom for god's sake don't
you panic that problem number one well
number eight how do you use the
restaurant number two i have a problem
with [ __ ] a car like gerard i have a
problem with him nodding off you know at
that other meeting i mean take this that
is actually true i have a bigger problem
no kidding but it's a metaphor for
everything every day there's something
about him that just doesn't seem
presidential and we're the ones that are
suffering because of it as a country
what am i doing here didn't they say
that literally about trump every day
doesn't seem presidential i'm going to
be so presidential when i get elected
who's they yeah but this goes back to my
my point when we get biden and trump out
of office to get someone actually
credible in there stop it with the
traffic i need you i need you to admit
right now on air that the guy you voted
for [ __ ] himself
i'll admit that you just admitted that
you [ __ ] yourself on the regular you've
never [ __ ] yourself not since i'm a
grown-up really it was four years old
maybe one time you've never proved yeah
not a heavy shirt this guy's not all
that too happy this is where we're at
right now this is your topic this is
where we're at right now all right so
this is great can we get some pampers
for gerard and joe biden while we're at
it look this seems to be quite the [ __ ]
show
there you go kai's officially comedian
good kada was impressive good for you so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]